all
right welcome everybody we do have a
quorum I I Quorum is eight so we're all
our first item is to review the minutes
of the previous beeting which were sent
out and um are on the website do I have
a
motion second thank you does anyone have
any comments Corrections or um additions
to the
minutes all right seeing none those in
favor I those
opposed all right
thank very appropriate thank you all
right good morning
afternoon something like that it's one
or the other I'm pretty sure all right
we the major item we are going to do
today is have Senator Bradley Bradley
explained to us his funding constraints
now that we have the September Revenue
use and I believe he is on his way does
anyone have anything else of importance
to
here oh dear me all right I don't see
much either so
um in that case I'll just give a summary
of what where I think we're going if we
can agree on any of the plans that have
been
suggested we will make a recommendation
to the
legislature if we think if we don't have
one that we're ready to recommend today
which I have no idea if that's possible
if that might
happen then I think we will not meet
again for until we do have something to
talk about we've done a lot of
brainstorming and thrown a lot of ideas
out there but if we don't don't have a a
plan that we can recommend to implement
then you know it's just just a bunch of
us getting together to chat and I'm not
sure we need to do
comments okay anyone
else all
right yes
Senator I don't know you know Senator
com
I don't know but it looks like it she
left her uh her her paperwork so maybe
we need yes I'm sorry maybe we need to
pause briefly because I I do know that
there is some Hope on the Senate side
that we would have something that would
be agreeable and that we could look at
today and I understand the cost of the
of the proposal has come down even a
little more some more work so I hope
that we'll be able to have something
because um you know on the Senate side
uh we had a lot of conversation the last
day of session at on the four and our
Senate President suggested that we might
be able to bring something forward on
veto day so I think that is still a hope
but it depends on us all getting to it
depends on us doesn't it yes thank you
well if no one else has another
suggestion I think we will take a
15minute recess so that our delinquent
you
all right since we are all seem to be
here uh Senator Bradley you were going
to report on revenues and talk
about your uh your
recommendations
okay thank you madam chair um good
afternoon everybody
so uh we do have uh September revenues
now so September was actually a pretty
good month uh $37 million above
expectation um which for the
year was a 36.4 million above plan um
so that's
good um but I
think
when you look at the two proposals that
I've put out the amendment 2259 and 58
the 2.5% multiplier and the
2 um 25 and 2.5 the price tag on both of
them is you know significantly higher
and as I keep
stressing
um there's going to be an impact at some
point in time of the YDC settlement
process so um
I keep cas Cas in about for ways to try
and you know get these costs down um
which is you know why I propose the
split
multiplier um one thing that came back
to us from Marty and maybe he can
address this is GRS the
actuary uh did take Brian your
suggestions and run a scenario on it but
because it was complicated ated um they
only did it for the 2.5% multiplier they
need to run a full analysis for the
second multiplier of 2.25 and 2.5 so
I've spoken with a speaker I would have
no
problem
um you know that we move forward and ask
GRS to you know do the same for that
version according to what Mar already
got back to us with and this is maybe
where you would be able to answer
questions going with Brian's
suggestions of tying it to the date that
you
retire um
decreases the terminal funding by about
$14 million so would bring the
92.6 down to um 78.6 I believe
approximately it
was
so
that's correct Senator Bradley your
questions um would it be fair to say
that with
the the other plan the revised
multiplier it would the change should be
expected to be the same order of
magnitude but not as much um this this
one has a couple of additional moving
Parts
2259 uh because because of the reduction
in the age in service for the the five
to 10 year people so I I don't if GRS
was here they'd be kicking me under the
table saying I can't give a full answer
on that with any great certainty it will
it obviously will be lower than the
current cost because a a portion of the
membership is excluded from that those
expected not to reach the the service
retire go to service
retirement okay all right does anyone
else have senator
water thank you madam chair and um so
Marty does these most these most recent
calculations um take into account any
reduction in the size of the pool the
numbers that might be covered it didn't
um and and there's a little bit of
background on that that that's sort of
the the
standard Actuarial practice for all
fiscal analysis of bill so that they all
have the same Baseline so we're working
off the you know the prior fiscal year
data there there is obviously a decline
in the population since then of of
people who've left service so that that
will have a reduction on the um you know
on the actual cost shown here to some
extent but you know it's it's it's it's
that that reduction in the cost is
depending on when is the effective day
how many people are going to be you know
there at the time you know if if this if
something were to pass so but it is it
is safe to say and and GRS would be okay
with that that you know because the
population is declining you know over
time you know these numbers are based on
a larger population so it's going to be
a little bit
less okay thank you other question
Senator Susi if I may in the amendment
for 2259 and not to get you in trouble
with GRS Marty but do do you have a
rough idea of what portion of the
membership is would fall under the 2.25
is that the larger portion or is that
the smaller portion let me see if I have
that with me I might not have brought
that particular document today
um I I don't have that with me I can I
can I can email the commission we have
that number I think it was on some of
the handouts that might have got posted
prior to the uh to the beginning of the
commission convening but I'll I'll dig
that out I should have had that with me
is this page Marty yeah uh no it's it's
the color bars um so might it was on a
previous handout which unfortunately I
didn't I didn't bring along if you could
provide it that would be helpful thank
thing
Senator thank you madam chair and this
is maybe as much for Senator Bradley as
for Marty I mean I know our goal is to
terminally fund uh and I understand
certainly despite the good revenues the
big uncertainties that we face
um but Senator Bradley do you think
there are ways in which we could um
terminally fund but have the funding um
be spread out over a little longer time
immediately so that would be a question
that I'd want
to maybe this committee would want to
invite mik Kaine to talk about um
obviously House Bill 436 had that kind
of scenario where over five budgets $25
million was no I'm sorry $50 million 25
per year was allocated in each fiscal
so I like your uh
ringtone
um it still has the potential issue
of a future legislature
not being willing or able to fund
whatever that commitment might be if we
were
to yep you know take Amendment 2259 for
example so it's $58 million and we
terminally funded half of that in this
budget
29 then there's still the exposure of
what might happen to that $29 million
that would be necessary to terminally to
fully complete the terminal funding and
if it's not all one lump sum again this
would be a question for the actuaries
probably but would that change the level
of terminal funding too a little bit a
little bit at least yes yeah
so but that would be a way of
spreading out the
cost Senator gray um we're almost
talking like Amendment 2259 or
2258 is going to be where we go and
that's not where I can go okay uh that
those amendments
affect
1,731
people there is 4,9 66 people in tier
C they get
nothing
nothing in
52,6 45 people in group
one they get
nothing in
this
nothing
forward everyone in group two get
something does tier B get more than
really with group one in the proposal
that I put
forward is it a lot of money can I only
affect the ones that are state employees
and would the municipal alties have to
do something to affect their people yeah
but the cost would come back as a
negotiated item just like salaries are
when you
negotiate for fringe
benefits
so if I'm going to spend the
money I would you know rather have a
conversation if if the percentages that
I put forward uh weren't high enough or
whether they should be in different
years instead of raising everyone to
2.25 and at 20 years and 25 at 30 years
you know bring it down to 2.5 at 25
years or
whatever
again it's reasonable the cost is
something that I think that we can work
with um but if we raise those benefits
you know you know we are going to have
to come up with the money because we
can't take them back away after they
vested
people can't take them back so you got
to come up with the money it's just how
much pain it is if we fund it
incrementally how much pain it is to
come up with the rest of the money after
we decide what we can afford this time
so those are my comments thank
you anyone else represent
Lan thank you madam chair and I believe
this was discussed uh a meeting to back
this review of the retirement has become
much too broad in my opinion it was
initially focused on House Bill
436 uh the
1700 uh folks that were penalized I
believe with the actions that took
placed more than a decade ago and I
think the more we get out there about
different TI years the different uh
increases the group one group two we're
losing track of what at least the house
position was on 436 which got us to a
commission in the first place I just
would like to say that I think we're
really putting a lot more mud into the
water than we should and we should
really focus on what I thought the
commission would really be focusing on
and that's a group two tier to 1,700
plus retirees are potential retirees
that were penalized a decade ago thanks
comments Madam chair yes I sometimes the
internet is helpful uh and answer to
Senator Susie's question um as of the
end of fiscal 22 and our those charts
were broken down in the the current
tiers which is you know 8 to 10 6 to8 so
there were 723 group members between six
but less than 10 years of service and
another 420 who were in The 4 to six
range so if you cut that in half you're
a little bit over 900 so the
folks getting the two and a quarter
multiplier is you know somewhat less
total
real thank you madam chair I just would
like to respond respond to Senator
Gray's comments um it maybe perception
is reality in this case but uh I would
like to think that this has gone well
beyond restoring a benefit for 1700
members and it's become more about
public safety for the million and a half
citizens in the state of New
Hampshire state troopers are down 77
Troopers the Department of
Corrections has been having to use the
National Guard to staff their prisons
and professional firefighters are losing
firefighters at almost a rate of two to
one for what we can hire and what we can
retain I'm quite frankly tired of
hearing about the fact that New
Hampshire is the number one state for
not the the the men and women that work
in the fire service the Police Service
Corrections are some of the bravest
people I've ever met and had the the
luxury of working with but we have a
real problem
here and we're losing people in this
state and we need to find a way to keep
them and I'm sorry Senator gray but a a
bill that is has a $15 million price tag
is not going to cover the 60,000 people
in the entire retirement system that you
reasonable on June 7th and 8th Senator
Bradley you took the floor and you you
gave a word to your colleagues in the
Senate and I appreciate you coming here
and working on this issue and trying to
figure it out we we haven't been able to
get there
yet but we all listen to you and when I
say we all the firefighters the police
officers correctional officers in the
state sat there and and watched that
floor speech and we were instilled with
a sense of confidence that this was
going to get fixed and it was going to
get
done you gave your word to fix this
issue and you said we would watch
revenues throughout the summer and into
the early fall to see what those
revenues
did those revenues have been have
surpassed what we needed them to
be yet we continue to sit here and talk
about uh the fact that we're not going
to fund this in its entirety and I would
ask that this commission take a long
hard look at what the ramifications of
not dealing with this issue now will be
and I fear that it's going to result in
tragedy for the citizens of the state
and I don't think any of us want to have
to answer to that I would ask that we
please look at what revenues have done
stay true to what we said that we were
going to do and fix this issue once and
you
thank you Senator so
um I appreciate the um comments
of Brian's um I think we have looked at
revenues July and August
were um slightly below expectations the
plan in the combination of the two
months September was good no question
about that um but as I said you know
when a budget is put together you have
expected revenues and then
Appropriations based on those revenues
so we are that $36 million ahead but
we're not running the same kind of
surpluses that we did in the prior
budget which is when I said on the floor
that we had to look at you know those
revenues that was
what I was referring to the if we
continue to
generate those kind of surpluses this
becomes
easier but so far two of the three
months barely made expectations and the
third was good so it it is a small
snapshot we are the 36 million doll
ahead of expectations that's good but
the price tag we didn't know then what
the price tag was going to be um and
that was part of the the problem we
didn't have time to have an Actuarial
analysis done of just doing the
multiplier we ran out of time and it had
been my hope that we would continue to
generate the same kind of surpluses so I
don't think we have generated the same
kind of surpluses because virtually
every month um in the prior f Year we're
running pretty hefty surpluses now some
months are bigger than others like May
is not a very big month because not much
revenue is due September is a big month
so that's good that's that's good and
October's a fairly substantial month too
November is not December is um we will
have a much better snapshot
having um seen what October
and yes November and December look like
in terms of because you know if we were
50 or6 million ahead right now I'd feel
a lot more confident that we were going
to continue to generate the kind of
surpluses but things you know have a way
of changing
and the uncertainty of Revenue is um
something that I think is building more
than I would have expected when I said
that in June so that's the unfortunate
reality of the situation in terms of
Revenue but again I guess I would
challenge all of us and I've made a
couple of suggestions obviously with my
two amendments to try to find ways to
move forward but
um you know keep the cost down and I
appreciate that that's what you're
trying to do
and um if
we analyze the impact on the Second
Amendment and um you know so I think if
this committee were to authorize that
then myself and the speaker could move
ahead because we can authorize the
expenditure of the funds for GRS to do
that and it's probably I mean my guess
is it's going to be somewhat less than
the $14
million um but that that would be
helpful and if there are other ways that
we can get the price tag down but still
accomplish the goal I think given the
that the revenue picture at least for
the first three months snapshot has
changed somewhat from the very flush
days
of um you know the last budget where
there were a couple of months that we
ran $100 million
surpluses I don't have all of those um
numbers here in front of me but I mean
that's why we're able to do a lot of the
things that we did in the
budget so the position we're in is that
we have a an amendment with a suggested
modification that will reduce the
expense by some amount does anyone have
any other suggestions that would lower
the cost while maintaining the intent of
that
[Music]
Amendment
Mr
R um I don't necessarily have a
recommendation but if I could speak to
what's being discussed I'd like
to briefly please do okay um I have some
concerns over the Second Amendment um I
just want to state that now before we
spend the money to have GRS do their uh
analysis of this and and all
transparency I'm trying to be fiscally
responsible myself here um but I do
believe that there
is a uh line of demarcation somewhere
that we we have to
identify uh to which we cannot fall
below um when we're talking about what
the benefit is that we're looking to
provide um I can tell you firefighters
in the state um probably will not be
happy um with the Second Amendment um
that we're discussing right now 22 2 58
uh excuse me 59 I believe it is um so I
would want to State on record that um I
would support obviously
2258 um and continue to look for uh
revenue for the next month or two to see
you thank you that's very valuable
information that the other Amendment
might not be totally acceptable
representative wilham you had a comment
no
okay Senator gray U Madam chair I'd like
to to at least comment on some of the uh
concerns that people uh expressed over
my
remarks um the duties of this commission
are not based on the house bill they are
based on the language that was put into
uh House Bill 2 uh which is chapter 79
page 18 and
19 uh and
talk nothing about the original House
bill that was issued uh and the first
one on uh line 28 and 29 says the we're
supposed to be studying the impact of
the retirement system will have on the
retention of employees and the ability
to attract new
employees and that's what I talked about
before is attracting those new
employees if I only concentrate on tier
C then how am I affecting the new
employees how am I going to provide a
safe condition for the citizens in the
Hampshire in the
future what we've done in part of
this in changing the retirement age back
is we made it easier for those long-term
employees to retire at a higher
rate we' have negatively impacted the
safety of the Hampshire citizens by
doing
that so I'm very confused you know this
this commission is more like a
negotiation session with the group two
people than it is looking at the whole
retirement system which is what house
fil to says we're supposed to be
doing thank you madam
CH thank you madam chair um you know I
really appreciate my my colleague
Senator Gray's concern about the the big
picture and um I certainly have not felt
that the focus on the one issue that you
know might develop a consensus Bill and
look at some terminal funding is not
meant to preclude whatsoever um
recommendations that might come out of
this Commission for legislation to to
address some of these larger issues
because I I agree completely with
Senator gray that we have to really
think about and what we've heard about
you know Recruitment and uh and
retention that there's a lot of issues
here and we can't wait to the next
decennial pension commission so I would
hope that you know as we have you know
if we can reach some kind of consensus
at some point in time over the immediate
issue that the Amendments that we've
been discussing and the actuary work
that we have done that then um we really
will be I I would hope um able to to
look more seriously at some of the
things that um Senator gray and others
want to propose about these other issues
because I agree the language there says
that uh we are you know we should look
at a broad range of of issues so I would
I would hate to think that you know that
we're really kind of foreclosing or
precluding that larger discussion
because we've already had some too we we
developed some good ideas that uh that
we brought forward and at some point we
might make some other recommendations as
well thank you madam chair yes I'd like
to say that um from the beginning I've
seen the the Committees work as having a
shortterm issue of something that
was started this past year relative to
the Gap group of of of group two and
also as Senator Ray pointed out we've
got to we also need to look at the
overall retirement system and see if if
it needs changes and we've done a bit of
brainstorming on that we haven't had
very much in the way
of significant proposals to
endorse but there have been Senator gra
made a couple
um
so at the moment the question is should
we continue brainstorming should we ask
for
a um Actuarial analysis and pay for it
on a proposal that may or may not be
satisfactory to everybody
to ask the commission to vote on whether
or not we
should ask for a Actuarial analysis of
the
tiered uh increase for group two we the
alterations recommended by Mr R so moved
okay is there a
second does any everybody understand the
idea the question no okay I see that uh
the the qu that would
be Senator Bradley's Amendment
2258 I believe 59 sorry
2259 which has a the multiplier change
and we've already costed that as
is plus the change recommended by Mr R
for uh people that leave prior to
their full date of service or full um
full age I'll second that Amendment I'll
second that motion okay thank you is
that does that uh characterize it
properly please
please uh I will I'll support this just
based on the fact that more information
is obviously better than less um again
with the assumption that very likely um
I wouldn't be able to support this
moving forward anything less than uh
okay all right does does everybody
understand the question again and Mr
Ford uh how much does an analysis like
that cost um less than 10,000 I
believe and it will be covered by the
legislator thank you I think Marty said
the two analysis that we've done so far
$7,500 that was the range gave us okay
one
well they'll if it's this one will be
more complicated than some because
they've got to estimate how many people
will retire at different ages because it
makes a
difference
okay so so the the motion is to request
the
analysis uh those in
favor
I any
opposed
all right I don't see any opposed but
there's a couple of abstentions so Mr
Carlin please go ahead and request that
analysis Senator gray um I'd like to
talk about having another analysis done
and that is on my proposal at the
bringing it to
2.25 at 20 years and 2.5 at 30 years is
what it would cost to bring it to 2.5
years and get that analysis done which
would significantly raise the $12
million which was alluded to in one of
the other statement excuse me Senator
could you you say
raise from what to 2.5 in the
proposals on sheet
two
um at the top of the page it says uh to
increase the
multiplier uh by 2.5 for the group two
members at 20 years and then increase It
Again by 2.25 to get to
2.5 or
0.25 to get to 2.5 at 30 years uh from
the multipliers that are currently in
statute right okay so your so that would
be that all the
employees would be at
2.25 for every year service starting at
20 years would be the thing that you'd
be analyzing and again that would affect
would not be retroactive because this
proposal here wasn't
retroactive retroactive and it would
give you a uh a much higher number if
that's you know what is being sought by
uh some uh for uh for the retirement but
it would affect tier B and tier C in
group two
employees okay
so to recap you're saying that every
group two person in either group in
either tier B or C who lasted to 20
years would have their multiplier
increased to 2.25 at 20 years or the
effective date of the change right when
it would for those people in tier B
right now again not retroactive well
they're all in they would be at two uh
one two two 2 three into four yes so
they would at 20 years they would all
which they would all be in right now
they would all go to uh 25 for the
remainder of their service so 25 after
how many years 20 but again it's I'm not
trying to make it retroactive so any
employee who is not at 20 years would go
to 25 at their 20 year anniversary
everyone
else as of the passage of the bill would
go to 25 for the remainder of their
service or if someone else wants to have
it analyzed differently I'm um Senator
I'm I'm sure you understand what you're
asking for but I'm afraid it doesn't
make sense to me Senator Bradley you
this is a question of Marty uh I believe
that you've already run much of this or
GRS has already run much of this
analysis because they've they've done it
at 20 years and at 30 years so this
would be relatively simple to have GRS
do would wouldn't that not be the
case probably um so I if I'm may I
repeat sort of what I'm hearing back and
make sure that um so so one one I I know
you were talking about you know as of
the effective date Senator gray but it
might be cleaner to if you say you know
the acrs for years of service are you
know between 2.0 and 2.5 for everybody
in group two right now or whatever they
are in the statute for their first 20
years of service and then at year 20 and
every year work thereafter they're recre
a 2 and a half% premium for those years
so it you know so so the longer you work
the the multiplier is larger after 20
years is that generally what you yeah
and the only difference would be whether
or not it was retroactive to someone who
at passage of the bill had 23 years of
service and was at a 2 point probably
two four four I think is with those
numbers where they would be now
uh but whether or not we we boost them
the extra or not I I'm willing to go
either way because it's it's all good
data yeah there there's like the first
year and a half of the people in the
transition table and that 8 to1 group
would have hit their 20 years and 2022
were this year is when they would have
started hitting that so they just became
eligible with the 46 and 21 to retire in
February so you know there's you know
I'm sure there's been some retirements
that cohort but um it's fair early in
that's and this proposal affects group
everyone who is currently
working in future hires as well and
future hires okay it is not just for the
the group be Senator Bradley you had a
comment so I I know that there's a lot
lot of angst about this proposal from
some folks and um but just as you
supported the analysis of 2259 I think
it would be appropriate to support the
analysis of Senator Grace Just because
more information even though it costs
money to get the information is probably
better than no information so I would
speak in favor of Senator Gray's
proposal at the 2.5% in 20 years okay
I'd like to mention that this would even
if we intended to terminally fund the
change that it would involve
a followon increase for uh for all the
employers once youve you've got people
that are in longer service employees who
pension yes representative lashman
thanks Madam chair with the last
proposal we voted on we actually saw an
amendment uh with language to support
the proposal do we have an amendment
that would support this
proposal uh I don't believe
so if you want to take a recess so that
we can draft it I'd be happy to do that
again you know I'm fighting for that uh
65.1% uh that the proposal that's uh
being evaluated doesn't affect those are
the ones I've been fighting for to give
them something to help the retention and
certainly if you want to take a recess
or you want to delay this until the next
meeting that can be done but the only
thing you're hurting is that 65% of the
people that the current proposal doesn't
affect
okay any other other questions or
comments
right just you know not withstanding
whether a formal amendment was drafted I
know certainly the retirement system in
the actuary would prefer the will of the
committee in sort of a written email to
you know so so we have something to
refer to we talked about it but just
just having it documented even in a
couple of sentence would probably be
best for all of us yes I agree with you
um however I think that if you think you
understand it and Senator gray thinks he
understands
it uh we'll let my confusion go away
and the question is do we think it's
worthwhile asking for an analysis of
this which would be an an improved
benefit
for
um all the group group two people in in
the
system and would would it be
acceptable
Senator GRE the written language and
taking what's on top of the page two
would be uh excuse me Senator please
don't say yeah great if you'd put it in
email it to me with the exact words you
want I'll I'll be and and the retirement
system well if the members have this um
it would be very easy for them to follow
along with what I'm going to say and can
email it to you in addition to that
please do so the words would be increase
the multiplier to
2.5% for all group two members for every
year exceeding 20 years
worked thank you thank
you all
right so this vote Yes Senator
Waters
if I I could ask a question Marty
um given what um Senator gray has been
proposing in this Actuarial study that
you will undertake is there a way of in
that study
to separate
out just those folks in the the tierc so
what I'm trying to get at is if we did
what we have been moving towards with
the other you know the other Amendment
but then we would have a separate number
which would give us let's say we did
that but then you know Senator gra say
what about these other folks would we
have a number that would be just that
group C then who would then get this
change I I I can inquire about that and
you know let let the commission know
what what the answer is I I initially
think that is possible I you know
honestly because the multiplier for the
TRC folks is
2.0% and it's an open-ended you know
group Rolling forward it's also the
majority now most of the cost of this
proposal will probably fall on that tier
because you know you're going from 2.4
to 2.5 for somebody uh you know so so
but I I can ask for a breakdown amidst
the tears there thank you thank you all
right so those who think we ought to ask
for this
analysis say I I I any
opposed one opposed okay thank you
all right so Senator gray will send to
to me and to Mark Marty Carlin the the
wording he wants to prefer and Mr Carlin
analysis and do you think two weeks
would be long enough to have it back and
uh think we got the
firsts
microphone I said I think it took two
weeks for the initial analysis of 228 58
and 59 so I'm assuming it's going to be
a similar ballpark I'm not sure what
their other workload is for us or other
clients at this time of year but I'll I
can get the the meter running on this
this afternoon after the meeting to to
let them know this is coming and you
know give them the details on the first
one
okay
well since it will since it sounds like
it might take longer than two weeks and
we want to get more
numbers um let's plan not to meet next
week
and the 26 will probably not be a good
day no okay thank
you all right so November
2nd do you think you will have October
data by that time or uh yeah we won't
have the final numbers but we'll close
enough pretty close yeah okay so in that
case I would suggest our next meeting be
November
2nd and for and at that meeting we will
have an update on revenues we will have
the cost analysis of Senator Gray's
proposal and of the
revised um short-term proposal from
Senator
Bradley with with Mr R's changes and is
there anything else that we should
discuss now or prepare to discuss at the
next
meeting okay Mr Fuller yes I'm not sure
if this is an appropriate time to bring
it up but just last time we met just I
brought some some thoughts forward so
I'm not sure if the members wanted any
more discussion on those on those items
or um so I know some of them too were
also some items for some future
Actuarial stuff or items being asked for
or just plain requests being made either
for the short term or the long term so
um whether we want I'm not sure if it
it's appropriate to bring that up for
now or well future it's if we are
ever if we're ever going to discuss
seriously I mean we did we got them and
we brainstormed a little uh which one or
ones in particular do you think we ought
on all right
so if it's okay I'll just briefly touch
upon so for instance proposal number one
with like reestablishing a cola account
that wouldn't be something that I'd be
proposing that we obviously do anytime
that would be more of an assessment of
the cost of things so I'm not really
sure I I know I know bringing up colus
but um so again that be that that's more
in the assessment category anyways um uh
proposal number two which was the Port
staff inclusion and that was the uh that
was extending the pension system to
part-timers yes I think there's a whole
lot more issues involved with granting
benefits to part-
timers and I I don't know if we have the
the skills or the knowledge to deal with
that without a lot of
research uh so i' I'd be opposed to
taking it up okay
and proposal number Stacey you oh thank
you madam chair I'd like to comment on
that because we did my group did speak
on that and we are absolutely opposed to
that um basically you know obviously
everybody has a lot of open positions
but one of the things at the at the
counties is we have a lot of part-time
positions that are filled by people who
have retired from the county and they
come back they are the ones that cost us
actually the least amount to have and uh
you know basically we've spoken I've
spoken with the HR people as well as
many departments and they said they
don't see this as a recruitment or
retention it's not a tool so I mean if
that's one of the things that we're
looking at is trying to retain and
recruit people this isn't one of them
because people who working part
part-time aren't looking for a career at
the county so it appear it appears that
the schools have set up a career path
for part-time employees and I think
that's both too spe very specific to the
schools and it
involves us in a whole lot of other
questions with labor law that I'm I'm
not sure I would extend a a defined
benefit pension as the
first benefit for a part-time
person so I mam
CH
very I have to be recognized I would
welcome that discussion because I think
the overall mission of this group this
commission involves a lot more than we
did and we did start a good discussion
back then and I do appreciate the
comment from the
municipal uh area I know that it is
always enticing to have positions they
full-time cut them up in two part times
and then pay no benefits it's a it's a
way to double dip into the system where
you get the work but you you're not
paying the benefits you know but the
cost gets passed on to everybody else to
pay that's what happens to the cost that
it just gets pushed back and somebody
else gets to pay so it's never a free
thing it's a free loading thing but it's
never a free thing somebody pays for it
every time you got a position that is a
retirement position and you have
somebody come back and work because I'm
already retired what do I do when they
in fact the right thing to do is this
when you work this positions they
retirement positions you should pay so
you work you pay it doesn't matter if
it's 1 hour 20 hours or 40 hours if you
already retired you're not going to
retire again but we already have a
system for that and it's called this
when somebody works at the retirement
system and doesn't retire and leave what
happen to the money it doesn't evaporate
it stays in the system so we already
have a system to that but it's important
that the employer should be paying to
the retirement system so we don't get to
push back the paying back because this
is really the the the the bleeding that
happens in the system it's not just one
way there's two ways so that's important
another thing I like to say is this
there should be a way that when you are
already vested retired so you vest in
the retirement system but you left for
whatever reason and you already vested
you have money in the system if you come
back to a position it should be a way
that the employee should be able to
contribute back again per hour one hour
20 or 40 whatever hours you work we
already have a system for that so all
these things are win-win we have systems
already in place we don't have to
reinvent the wheel we have a system to
that and I do understand that every time
you talk to about employer how about
making that contribution to retirement
system you you know the position is well
it's free it's cheaper and all that
nothing there are some savings that we
cannot afford this is a savings that's
very expensive for many people for
taxpayers for the retirement system and
for the unfunded Liber not not only that
it's wrong and we should change that to
correct that i' like to mention that we
had a bill this past year that would for
uh penalize employers that canceled a
retirement system job and replaced it
with a parttime job uh we couldn't work
out the details but I believe the the
intent of it is coming back so I think
that would be an appropriate way to say
how do we how do we deal with the
situation of employ employers or
employees for that matter trying to game
the system in this
regard because it's going to require a
law change to do it I appreciate that
and I'm welcome to have that discussion
because the real gaming that happens is
when you terminate a full-time position
you can break it up in two part-time
positions and then you say you're going
to pay no benefits not just the
retirement benefits but no other
benefits at all whatsoever that is wrong
for our economy and we should not be
doing that so I appreciate that and as
well as finding a way that somebody
who's already deferred vested and left
for whatever reason you come back you
should be paying to the retirement
system I would like to do that if I was
a person paying I would have no problem
paying as well I have 36 years in if I
retire and come back I should be paying
to the retirement system and if somebody
says but you're already retired but no
difference than somebody else who worked
three years and left have the money
there the money is there doesn't
evaporate and and and you have already a
system to that I think it would be a
fair thing to do and we should look into
that thank you thank
you Mr Fuller and and I I I appreciate
the comments on that too so and I
appreciate what you're saying as well as
they get get will get a little bit
complicated just one quick comment on
that because I actually want to talk
more about the vesting one right here
next but um I want to make clear because
I know there was some prior comments in
our other meeting people would be
concerned about people wanting to just
you know all of a sudden get all their
benefits in the last year it would be a
percentage base so for instance if
you're only working like say 20 hours
you the proposal would be that you would
only get like half the benefit so I mean
there's nothing here in terms of wanting
to allow the door to open so that people
could get full-time benefits with only
working parttime so that's not the
intent and if I wasn't clear I was just
wanted to clarify that real quick so um
but actually I wanted to really mention
here I wanted to briefly go over all of
them but just with the vesting one right
here which was number three um
established five years of credible
service would be considered to be
vesting and again that would match us up
with our with our neighbors because
especially with the amount of years we
need vesting right now um establishing
only a fiveyear mark of being vested um
I think that would be a really great
tool to again to attract and retain our
workers so
okay again I I just want to comment that
we support that we do we see that as a a
very good attention recruitment tool is
is reducing it down because what we're
seeing at the counties is a lot of
younger people who the 10year mark they
they just don't see it as attainable
five years probably is more palatable so
we would be in favor of that okay
Senator Waters thank you madam chair um
on that that last one of the vesting and
the five or the 10
um you know after our discussion last
time and it did seem to me the the word
we were hearing that that really
potentially would not have a financial
impact um and so my question kind of to
my Senate colleagues because we're still
in a filing period is if if either now
or maybe in February the late filing if
this is something that this commission
reaches a consensus on maybe we could
put something uh in in in February or
even by four o'clock today but I again I
I I think it's we need to know that that
idea I hope we don't lose it um I think
it makes a lot of sense and it would be
possible to act on it this year if the
commission has consensus I think we
could find a vehicle to do
it okay yeah that the impact on that
would be that someone who left between
five and 10 years would be eligible at a
future date to receive a pension
and
um so I don't think we would have a very
large effect but there would be some Mr
that uh yeah so so essentially since
since pensions are currently calculated
uh years of service is an important
factor in that equation somebody with
five or six years who left and then
they'd have to wait until they reach
whatever the statutory eligibility age
or other requirements are in there they
get a a pension on that that the
percentage of their average final salary
would be much smaller than somebody who
worked a full career um another um thing
the director Goodwin just mentioned too
is with um with employee um employer
employee refunds and I talked about that
a couple weeks ago where people if they
terminate before vesting or even after
they can get their money back plus the
interest it may reduce the amount of
people seeking refunds you know because
they'll just kind of let it ride for a
small
stream of income and
retirement uh making the calculations
much more
complicated all right Senator Bradley
question thank you madam chair has the
actuary actually looked at um this has
there ever been a bill that's been
analyzed no we've never had this as
legislation I mean I I I can put the
question to them when we're sending over
these other analysis is just you know
without doing in full analysis there's
any way to give an order of magnitude
impact on something like that they may
say no we need to look at it more detail
but I we can ask that preliminary
question if obviously if a a proposal
was put in as a as a bill you know they
they do the full analysis for sure it
would be an extremely simple bill you
just have to change 10 to five in I
think two places yeah um but the but it
should be actually consider considered
as a bill separate from everything else
because that would be a a retention tool
that might or might not be worth the
cost when we don't know what the cost is
yeah Mr re you had a comment I was just
going to ask Madam chair if it would be
appropriate uh for this commission to
make a motion on that but you may have
just answered my question yes please if
you wish to make a motion uh yes I'd
like to make a motion that this
commission um draft language that would
EST establish uh a vesting period of
five years for the retirement system
I'll second it okay
seconded Miss Stacy got in before you
all right so the intent of this is that
we would change the statute to establish
five-year vesting for all people in the
retirement system
and put it in as a bill for next year
which will then receive the full
Actuarial analysis
Senator Bradley um could I ask you Brian
to amend your
motion and ask Senator
Waters instead of making a
recommendation that the committee
recommends that we do this recommend
that Senator Waters file that as a bill
and he has two hours and 13 minutes to
do it um my colle Senator Susi like to
Okay the reason for that is
then this discussion then would not be
like do we support five years do we not
support five years not be in a vacuum I
think that Kathy makes a good point um I
don't know Dave if you have any thoughts
from the municipal
Association i' I'd like to know what the
cost is if it's a nominal cost I would
agree with the Employers in the room
that as well as the employees is
probably a good idea but that way if the
motion was Senator Waters filed the bill
or Senator Susi filed the bill then that
whole analysis and the public hearing
happened so I'd I'd be more comfortable
with that I'm happy to amend my motion
to have Senator I would second that okay
as long as it's Senator Susi or Waters
that files the bill I see those
Democrats you're trying to say right no
Waters it's because you were bragging or
was the senator Susi bragging you only
have four
bills as long as it he basically means
somebody other than Senator Bradley yes
okay everyone understand the
motion and then the maker of the second
only motion we have to agree the motion
was made by yeah was amended by yes made
and amended by Mr R seconded by Miss
Stacy both times okay those in favor
I
opposed okay Senator you've uh got your
got your marching
orders
okay okay Mr Fuller okay then I'll I'll
be quick I don't want to hold anybody up
and this the the last two things I I
brought up on previous were about um the
definition of earnable compensation and
then also the uh potential change in AFC
calculations so I just didn't know if
anyone else had any other thoughts on
those items or
uh I'd like to mention that when we made
what we thought were incredibly trivial
changes to to that in House Bill 436 it
ended up being better than $60
million um Mr Carla yeah actually with
um House Bill 436 and also House Bill
579 last year which would have restored
the three-year average final
compensation with the other pay types
included in it for group two we we as a
retirement system on our dime did ask
the actuary what the cost would be
analogous just for tier B in group one
because just sort of trying to
anticipate fusure impact so that that's
actually on on the last page of the grid
there's a couple of group one uh
projections and this is this is the
approximately 11,000 members in group
one tier B if you brought them back to a
three-year AFC with V retirement
incentive payouts leave payouts things
like that that's about
187 million on the UA plus an employer
contribution uh increase it's
nominal so that so we did it similar
that's not split out that's not one of
the other and you couldn't really cut it
in half but it gives you an order of
magnitude idea of of what that would
would
entail Miss Stacy so I will just um
Madam Shar just say that we in
opposition to both those
changes thank
you
okay anyone else have a have something
discuss
okay so so we will we will get our
aterial analysis we will have a bill in
the Senate on fiveyear vesting and we
will meet again on November 2nd
all